[Musica]
all
io sono pochi per raccontarvi una storia
che la storia che parte da una ferita
tutta mia
ma è anche la storia che racconta come
questa ferita pian piano è riuscita ad
aprirsi a far entrare i sogni degli
altri in qualche modo diventare il sogno
di una città intera
devo parlare di me e non è sempre
facilissimo farla circa 15 anni fa
lavorava nel campo della comunicazione
per una professionista aveva una vita
normale anche felice ho deciso di fare
un figlio
e quel figlio però è esattamente una
passeggiata perché il mio bambino nera
come gli altri
il mio era un bambino fra gilera un
bambino diverso
mio figlio era un bambino disabile
quando nasce un bambino disabile lo
racconto quando me lo chiedono ed è
un'altra espressione se non quella di un
treno un treno in faccia tutto quello
che erano le aspettative verso una vita
quello che l'aspettativa verso una
maternità ci sono completamente infrante
davanti a quello che era accaduto io non
ho avuto i fiori non ha avuto sciocco
sulla porta azzurro rosa non ha avuto
tutte quelle cose hanno potuto neanche
lavare i pannolini
la mia esperienza di mamma è stata
un'esperienza dove esistevano fili
incubatrici diagnosi è la cosa più grave
che mi è accaduta è stato che è un certo
punto mi sento proprio rubato il futuro
queste sì mamma davanti un figlio e
spera nel suo futuri non potevo guardare
avanti neanche un giorno un'ora
neanche una settimana perché mi più
fidati che non sarebbe accaduto
pian piano però diciamo che la vita si è
evoluto è cambiata siamo sono riuscite
ad affrontarla e la ripresa i suoi
colori
ho cominciato da a guardare cercare di
risolvere dei cammini di ritornare ad
esistere e di farmi di farmi cambiare da
quella esistenza non riuscivo più essere
quello che ero perché martino mi stava
profondamente cambiando e non riusciva a
rimanere la persona che era a fare il
lavoro che stavo facendo
nel cercare di capire che la mia figlia
io ho incontrato la persona che avete
incontrato prima incontrato bruna pian
piano ci siamo resi conto che martino
erano essere pieno profondo pieno di
pensieri pieno di parole martino un
ragazzo zitto come giovanni e non parla
ragazzo tetra pareti con spastico quindi
è in carrozzina non si muove non mangia
in continente ma è profondamente
intelligente profondamente pieno
profondamente umano
queste sono alcune delle parole che lui
scrive quella io penso che dicono tante
cose quindi le ho portate per avere
vedere questa martino pian piano cosa
accaduto però che anche io ero cambiata
e non potevo più continuare occuparmi di
toni di fucsia di t shirt di moda di
design e ho cercato una risposta ha
dentro di me cos'è accaduto io ho
cominciato a unire due cose che avranno
successo nella vita quindi la mia
passione per il design la mia la mia
esistenza e lui quindi la fragilità e
siamo un gruppo di amici
fondiamo che i lab che lab è un progetto
dove creatività fragilità e si
incontrano e dove vengono sviluppati
progetti creativi insieme ai ragazzi con
fragilità
siamo partiti dalle parole dalle parole
in questo caso erano quello che volete
di mio figlio ma erano anche quelli di
altri trenta ragazzi con fragilità come
lui che hanno queste parole che si io
penso che siano pietre seno parole come
quelle che avete sentito prima sono
ungarettiana perché sono faticose sono
piene sono devono essere lì e vengono
dette quando devono proprio essere lì
quindi hanno cominciato con quadri poi
con t shirt e poi con oggetti pian piano
abbiamo conosciuto altre fragilità e
quindi oggi siamo sono circa 300 le
persone qui da dai ragazzi zitti ma
anche ragazzi che disegnano che
assemblano che fanno cose con cui stiamo
lavorando per realizzare quello che un
sogno quello che diceva prima giovanni
il futuro di una vita intelligente poi
cos'è accaduto io ho questo è anche un
libro che ho scritto sulla sua storia
diciamo che pian piano mi sono appunto
ritrovata come persona per caduto
qualcosa accaduto che mi hanno chiesto
mi ha chiesto il mio sindaco ma chiesto
anche la mia città di candidarmi a delle
elezioni quindi di fare un percorso
politico
io non sapevo come affrontarlo fino a
quando non ho capito che dovevo trovare
dentro di me
il motivo proprio quella già tela poteva
indossare il motivo perché potevo fare
perché potevo fare questa cosa per la
mia città e mi sono pian piano inventata
un progetto che si chiama reggio emilia
città senza barriere ma da qua e un po
userò noi perché oggi non è più un
progetto soltanto mia ma un progetto che
fa parte di una città intera perché
siamo in tantissimi portali
ed è partito da qua questa è una mappa
che somigliano moltissimo alla mia che
la mappa di una mamma con tutte quelle
forze che deve aprire per gestire la
vita di una persona fragile di suo
figlio quindi voi vedete scuola supporto
salute sviluppo sono tutte le porte le
persone e poi lei un'altra mappa con
tutti i cellulari che ovviamente non ho
portato per tutti i contatti per
riuscire a gestire la vita di questo su
questo suo ragazzo fragile e della
stessa cosa che facevo io e che fanno
tutte le famiglie come me da lì ho
pensato abbiamo pensato di provare a
ribaltare la prospettiva quindi non
pensare a un progetto di welfare calato
dall'alto ma proviamo a provare per
ripartire dalle esigenze delle persone e
quindi parlare con le mamme con i papà
con tutte quelle persone che sapevano
veramente cosa serviva loro e in questo
modo diciamo che è nato questo progetto
che ha fondamentalmente avuto quattro
macro argomenti nove tavoli di lavoro è
poi accaduto una cosa è accaduto che la
città intera è arrivata
il progetto mi è scoppiato fra le mani e
siamo tantissimi oggi che abbiamo
lavorato su nove tavoli di lavoro che
fanno un po a lavorare tutti quelli che
sono gli aspetti della vita di una
persona con disabilità al di là della
cura
quindi quello che sembrava essere la
necessità primaria quindi pulirsi il
mangiare lo string luoghi dignitosi era
diventato proprio semplicemente la
partenza da cui questa città poteva
lavorare
ovviamente perché questa città aveva
quelle quelle caratteristiche di base e
quindi siamo date occupare tutto quello
che andava al di là della cura per cui
le passioni le emozioni gli interessi la
sessualità l'affettività l'anima che poi
quello che ognuno di noi fa tutte le
mattine ma che spesso per una persona
fragile data per scontata e invece no
noi siamo andati proprio lì da qui sono
partiti appunto tantissimi progetti
questo per farvi vedere notte di luce
che una serata in cui tutta la città di
reggio emilia arriva e si spengono le
luci vengono accesi migliaia di candele
per testimoniare l'importanza la
differenza e della disabilità come
risorsa e quindi poi pian piano anche
della fragilità i progetti sono
tantissimi non ve li voglio elencare
sono 49 progetti che
in una spa di 34 persone abbiamo
sviluppato nell'arco di alcuni anni
proprio perché non sono più da mostri
sono diventati veramente di tutti i
regimi di avuto una una cosa io credo la
capacità il coraggio di essere fragili
il coraggio di dire che sono io sono
disabile il sono matto io sono faccio
fatica e di prendere questa fatica e
portarla a farla diventare una
opportunità per tutti gli altri
abbiamo fatto una palestra accessibile
per sé grave disabilità abbiamo fatto
progetti creativi dove arte e fragilità
si sono unite insieme e la cosa
incredibile l'effetto moltiplicatore che
la gente ha dato è il fatto che le
persone hanno portato veramente questa
il loro vissuto dentro questa questa
grande cosa che io credo se adesso città
senza barriere
poi pian piano diciamo che si è
ulteriormente amplificato il discorso
nel senso che proprio nel ragionare nel
pensare a progetti nuovi ci siamo
tornati a interrogare su una cosa è che
questa che vi abbiamo chiamato ha
diritto alla bellezza ci siamo chiesti
come mai
spesso i luoghi i progetti e le
situazioni legate alla fragilità in
qualche modo onesto lasciato la bellezza
fuori dalla porta fuori dall'uscio come
se in questa città soprattutto perché
siamo una bella città pratica dove siamo
bravi siamo siamo efficienti però siamo
a volte diciamo che soprattutto in
questo campo eravamo un po grigi per cui
si erano questi luoghi un po triste e
qui e quindi cosa ci siamo detti
abbiamo provato a capire come fare a
riportare la bellezza e provare dire che
bello e il buono potevano stare insieme
anzi che proprio perché se una persona
già fragile se noi la stiamo la rendiamo
la rendiamo e la mettiamo in luoghi
anche brutti facciamo con questa persona
cosa ti va di poco un poco valore
estetico e realtà la stiamo
marginalizzando a nostra volta è un modo
per offendere ulteriormente quindi siamo
detti abbiamo fatto partecipato a un
bando del ministero pari opportunità che
abbiamo vinto siamo arrivati secondi ma
con il maggior finanziamento nazionale
abbiamo provato a fare una cosa che
credo molto importante abbiamo provato a
scrivere il manifesto del diritto alla
bellezza partendo dalla fragilità quel
giorno abbiamo fatto un evento
partecipativo abbiamo scritto questo
manifesto che dice io credo cose molto
importanti
eravamo in tantissimi io non so come
raccontarvelo se non dopo con un video
che vi farò vedere perché anche qui
veramente stato un incanto qualcosa di
incredibile che una città interessa è
stato un giorno intero lavorare per
scrivere questo manifesto a qualcosa di
sognante di cui io sono molto orgoglioso
come cittadina
il manifesto cosa il progetto cosa vuole
fare vuole provare a dire che a provare
a migliorare i luoghi della fragilità
renderli luoghi belli
quindi abbiamo tantissimi architetti
ingegneri grafici che stanno venendo
come volontario per cercare di
migliorare questi luoghi vuole provare
anche a migliorare la progettazione dei
servizi e quindi a provare a dire che
all'interno di quella della rete dei
servizi la creatività la bellezza devono
esistere devono partecipare nel
quotidiano di questi ragazzi perché
proprio nell'incrocio tra fragilità e
bellezza ci siamo accorti che c'è una
capacità generativa incredibile
riabilitativa con che il labbro abbiamo
dimostrato perché i ragazzi le persone
fragili quando incontrano la bellezza
alzano la testa ma nello stesso tempo
anche quelli che sono i vari attori
della creatività nel impastarsi nel
toccare nel ritornare nei luoghi della
verità in qualche modo hanno una alzata
di sguardo e quindi questo incontro è un
po una magia e poi noi vogliamo anche
provare a far sì che le imprese della
città e quindi che le aziende stiano con
noi e provare a fare prodotti insieme
non soltanto come fa che come fa che il
app che fa benissimo ed è uno dei
partner del progetto
ma proprio come città intera per dire
rob anche mia per dire che la fragilità
non è questa una questione di addetti ai
lavori non è una questione di tecnica ma
è una questione di ognuno di noi ci
tocca da vicino e non possiamo
dimenticarci che esiste questo è la
giornata della della verità e bellezza
questo è un po la firma del manifesto
gas tarda sera quando dopo tante ore di
lavoro e io credo che non ci sono venuti
per dire per esempio max casacci
subsonica venuto paolo verri di matera
capitale europea della cultura
sono venuti tam architetti sono quelli
che costruiscono gli ospedali per
emergency è venuto tanto mondo tutti
mischiati tutti insieme per scrivere
questo manifesto
io poi il video che
spero che possa partire che racconta
quella giornata in cui abbiamo provato a
fare questa cosa tutti insieme
[Musica]